deux ans que moi ont été touées par les
fascistes en Italie et alors vraiment
j'avais un choc énorme ça m'est bloqué
même sexuellement après
c'est que la gonzesse est couchée avec
Hitler sinon il y a pas de problème en
même temps
un petit moment bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
parce que je suis pour ça alors ça va
Massimo très bien alors dites-moi
Massimo vous aviez 15 kilos à perdre cet
été vous avez perdu non au contraire
j'ai pris encore 5 donc ça fait 20 à
perdre pour l'été prochain
alors vous êtes chacun à sa croix bien
sûr j'ai calé Olivier si vous voulez
est-ce que vous êtes le vous êtes est-ce
qu'on peut dire que vous êtes le bouton
de train des riches un peu le chef du
protocole de la Jet 7
on m'appelle aussi l'homme de tous les
bonnets voilà c'est joli l'homme de tous
les bonheurs les riches ils ont beaucoup
d'argent ils savent pas comment le
dépenser et Massimo vous êtes faites
partie des gens qui les aidaient à
dépenser la salle
elle s'amuser j'ai tout dépensé tout ma
vie toujours je dépense avant de gagner
l'argent et alors vous organisez des
événements à commencer par the best
parce que de baisses c'est d'abord un
magazine et puis c'est aussi un
événement chaque année c'est une
cérémonie vous remettez les baisses aux
gens les plus élégantes c'est ça oui
c'est vrai je vais donner à lui la
prochaine
[Rires]
alors on va raconter un petit peu la vie
de Massimo Gardia qui a une vie très
très étonnante ce soir on a d'ailleurs
beaucoup de beaucoup de destins
étonnants avec vous avec ivana Trump
avec
c'est vraiment des gens qui ont des
destins incroyables alors vous étiez un
jeune napolitain désargenté au départ
hein et puis vous avez passé votre vie
en fait à mener une vie de milliardaire
de la jet-set donc j'ai plutôt bien
réussi vous êtes content aux résultats
j'avais 20 kg de moins
alors vous dites finalement cette vie si
c'est pas le bonheur c'est l'illusion du
bonheur au moins oui tiens vous avez le
sentiment de vivre dans une espèce de
bulle de champagne toute votre vie comme
ça mais oui c'est déjà beaucoup avoir
l'élodion
vous publiez un livre qui s'appelle Jet
7 ah vous ne faites pas même si moi
j'appelle Jet 7 donc les mémoires d'un
playboy international chez Michel le
plafond et c'est ma Simo Gardia et c'est
un livre très très étonnant moi je l'ai
lu au départ bon je croyais que c'était
très superficiel que c'était très léger
frivole et en fait c'est vrai c'est
sincère et c'est très étonnant à cause
de ça préface de Françoise Sagan
Françoise Sagan est une amie on peut
dire le Massimo en rester là pour le
moment et ça pourrait être très con ce
bouquin et c'est génial et d'ailleurs je
suis pas le seul à avoir dit parce qu'il
y a des critiques littéraires en France
qui ont qui ont reconnu que c'était
autre chose qu'une compilation de
souvenirs de jet setter on va vous
raconter bon ben la Jet 7 au début ça
s'appelait La Café Society il y a des
familles de la haute société
internationale et puis petit à petit il
y a eu des grosses familles
industrielles comme les Agnelli
justement elle est Rothschild et puis
quand Grace Kelly est arrivé à Monaco
finalement ça a été le début des acteurs
dans la Jet 7 le début des couturiers
dans la jet-set et ça a commencé à
vraiment changer à ce moment-là quoi à
s'ouvrir un peu à s'ouvrir au monde
parce que on n'est pas aucune n'existait
pas et les stages sont devenus les
mannequins les modèles et les coutur
sont devenus très importants les
bijoutiers aussi et puis d'un seul coup
quand même maintenant c'est devenu très
très marquant il a déjà 7 non non
les visages du monde à changer c'est
naturel qui est même la mandarité
changer quoi alors Massimo gardien donc
est né en
on peut le dire qu'elle n'est pas que
vous êtes né si c'est nécessaire
donc vous vous êtes rentrés dans la Jet
7 en 1965 à l'âge de 24 ans comme ça on
sait à quelle heure
[Applaudissements]
alors donc vous êtes rentrés dans le G7
en fait grâce à Pierre Cardin vous
connaissez Pierre Cardin oui bien sûr
les garages puis regardant les chocolats
et alors
tout de suite vous étiez très très beau
vraiment magnifique c'est pas vous êtes
mal maintenant mais franchement vous
étiez craquant et alors tout de suite
une femme vous prend sous son aile
j'ai dit comme ça
une dame de 60 ans qui s'appelait Cécile
de Rothschild ça a été la première
finalement la sœur du baron à
l'hydrotschild qui s'est occupé de vous
quoi et vous dit d'ailleurs dans votre
bouquin vous dites j'étais jeune et
vigoureux et j'adorais séduire il était
très vigoureux Massimo
et alors vous dites je m'efforçais de ne
pas me muer en simple gigolo pourquoi
parce que vous savez si vous comparez
c'est dans une scène de la société et
vous arrivez comme gigolo vous êtes
marqué à vie alors c'est vraiment quand
on est à 24 ans et qu'on sort avec une
femme riche de 60 ans c'est difficile de
pas être taxé de gigolisme non
en effet beaucoup de gens au début on
pensait ça des mois mais j'ai démontré
après que c'était pas vrai bah vous
dites j'accepté ces cadeaux mais j'ai
forcé de ne pas me faire entretenir oui
j'ai eu tellement des succès avec les
personnes les personnes j'ai plusieurs
personnes je n'ai pas dit dans les
livres je voulais pas blesser qui sont
essayés de suicider pour moi j'avais
beaucoup de succès et mes fessiers des
cadeaux extraordinaires et moi je dois
dire la vérité j'adorais les cadeaux
malheureusement
la question importante c'est bon à
l'époque vous étiez un playboy
ou
alors
gigolo Playboy moi je préfère préparer
Playboy d'accord alors Cécile de
Rothschild on continue parce que c'est
que le début ça Cécile de Rothschild
vous présente une amie à elle sa
meilleure amie Greta Garbo
les mobylettes
aussi Greta Garbo donc avait 64 ans et
vous 25 mais alors à l'époque elle était
dans une phase de Greta gargou de
réclusion extrême non elle est sortie
plus du tout elle se montrait plus et
voulait plus sortir moi j'ai essayé de
la sortir de la ressortir de tout ça
vous dites en parlant Greta garbol à
l'époque elle était d'une botter
renversante un visage presque enfantin
malgré ses 64 ans
vous la remarqué immédiatement il avait
la façon dans laquelle elle a marché
même si tu n'étais pas aux femmes
une beauté elle avait ses années mais
elle avait quelque chose
d'extraordinaire si elle entrait dans
une chambre j'ai tout de suite c'est
marrant quand même alors vous dites
d'ailleurs un truc c'est que Greta Garbo
préféré la compagnie des femmes d'une
façon générale elle préfère aussi bien
sur le plan social que sexuel elle met
bien les femmes quoi d'une façon
générale oui j'ai eu l'impression
qu'elle était pas folle physiquement de
moi préférée m'accompagner comme pour
l'accompagner tout ça
mais parce qu'elle était une femme très
seule et ça me faisait beaucoup avec moi
et moi je lui parlait jamais du cinéma
elle détestait pas les gens
passer et c'était une femme qui n'avait
pas le système nerveux pour supporter
tous la célébrité qui était tombée sur
les épaules c'est très dur vous
comprenez pas
très elle préférait les filles le
triolisme aussi avec le couple
dans le bouquin oui ça va nous chauffer
là c'est une scène dans le bouquin de
Massim lui dit bah voilà son honneur de
Playboy est en jeu quoi il dit un moment
il faut y aller il fallait il me fallait
posséder la star la plus célèbre du
monde parce que à mon époque c'était une
Nantes sorti avec une femme et pas
couché avec quoi c'est pas beaucoup
aujourd'hui c'est fini ça c'est fini
n'allez pas oui donc Massimo il va dans
le noir ça s'est passé dans le noir avec
Greta Garbo ah c'est elle voulait les
Noirs absolus
son frère et alors vous dites j'ai du
même obscurer la porte
et alors le lendemain vous la trouvez
très froide en fait avec elle
voulait pas épiloguer comme dit certains
et alors en fait vous dites elle
pratiquait le sexe avec moi uniquement
pour me faire plaisir oui j'avais
l'impression
un peu plus avec toi pour te faire
plaisir elle a été pas passionnée alors
bon ça lance votre carrière et puis
alors il y a un épisode évidemment
fameux c'est qu'un jour vous avez des
amis paparazzi et vous organisez une
séance voilà vous arrivez à l'aéroport
de Milan à gretables parce que vous
comprenez un garçon qui vient d'énormes
et qui sort avec la femme la plus
célèbre du monde c'est terrible pour
appeler bon alors j'ai pas résisté j'ai
résisté je tiens à la fin j'ai pas
résisté un ami à moi m'a dit j'étais à
moi en photo là il y avait trois
photographes et voilà et alors elle m'a
dit elle m'a dit
en anglais naturellement je veux dire
français tout
m'a pris tu m'as eu une fois tu n'auras
jamais plu voilà ça a été fini ça a été
fini pour toujours
Grace Kelly aujourd'hui on a Philippe
Kelly classique
[Applaudissements]
et encore mais non c'est une amitié
amoureuse Sagan elle dit en parlant
parce que tu es marié à l'époque elle
dit en parlant de son mari là la
trahison et le seul moyen d'assurer la
survie d'un mariage
elle a raison je suis tout à fait
très intelligence mais dans beaucoup de
liberté d'autres d'autres aventures
ailleurs tout ça parce que quand la
liberté vous n'avez plus envie c'est les
gens qui sont
ici de savoir comment se démerder la
semaine dernière
c'est certain de lui expliquer que la
fidélité c'était dans la tête dans la
tête
et alors je t'adore Michel Sagan vous
apporter en plus une touche culturelle
pour vous c'était vachement bien parce
que quand même bon
les autres mais regardez avec elle parce
que François naturelman n'a jamais parlé
de littérature avec moi ça m'intéresse
pas elle préfère parler de ça avec
Bernard friend alors il a alors on
arrive aux choses importantes mesdames
messieurs parce que Massimo a 31 ans
vous découvrez que vous n'avez jamais
travaillé vous refusez d'épouser une
riche héritière non en effet je
détestais l'idée de mariage au fond il y
a en vérité que j'étais appelé boy née
parce que j'ai toujours détester les
mariages l'idée d'être prisonnier de
rentrer toujours tous les soirs avec la
même femme l'idée d'être obligé d'être
là non j'ai toujours détesté
vous écoutez les enfants là
j'aime bien compris c'est vrai et là
vous rencontrez Julie Lescaut et
l'Empire pire
pire pire Lydia détering alors il faut
dire qui c'est l'idéal était parler
beaucoup dans votre livre mais en deux
mots c'était la c'était l'épouse du
propriétaire
la chaîne voilà c'est ça c'était la
femme de Monsieur shell petite boutique
quoi petite boutique donc monsieur
Chelles était mort le pauvre et donc
elle avait 80 ans elle était là et en
chasse de chair fraîche et alors ça
commence très fort pour avoir dansé
sauvagement avec cette dame Lydia
Massimo obtient une montre en or
quartier mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
depuis que je l'ai connu depuis le soir
que je l'ai connu pendant un mois tous
les jours ma moyenne un cadeau tous les
jours
des montres des choses un tableau
partout
Massimo flirté avec les diabéternés
un petit Piou quoi et vous savez ce
qu'il y a eu pour pour le plus quoi pour
le plus c'était un Internet rue de la
Faisanderie dans le 16e et oui mais
d'abord faut le faire et là vous avez
peur de pas y arriver là vous vous dites
à un moment la première fois mais vous
avez une réaction
d'ailleurs vous dites bon les
sexagénaires pardon elle avait 80 un peu
plus de 80 ans non alors ce qu'il faut
vous dire les enfants attendez
ez vous voulez bravo
si vous voulez
un appartement rue de la Faisanderie
alors
plus rue de la Faisanderie
et alors non ce que je dis Massimo à ce
moment-là
se dit bon les sexagénaires que ça soit
Cécile de Rothschild ou Greta Garbo ils
avaient 60 ans 60 ans il y a pas de
problème mais là c'est 80 mes enfants et
qu'est-ce qu'il fait Massimo qu'est-ce
qu'il fait il boit un petit coup de
champagne
deux bouteilles et alors torcher vous y
arrivez
et alors page 137 je signale la page 134
minutes
je dis après que à la fin j'étais
conquis pareil c'est ce que vous dites
vous dites bon effectivement
elle avait pas fait l'amour depuis
longtemps donc dit Massimo il me sembla
pénétrer une jeune vierge c'est ça c'est
le cinéma qui fait
massimoine une vierge experte en jus de
sexuelle c'est à dire que vous avez été
très surpris par rapport finalement par
l'énergie au lit de Lydia d'interding
qui avait donc un peu plus
aimé par les femmes et vous dites c'est
un pianiste
après mais c'est très très mal terminé
et alors donc voilà le lendemain vous
êtes chez le notaire et vous avez votre
appartement
rue de la Faisanderie et voilà c'est pas
compliqué quand même non mais c'est il
faut avoir la forme il faut il faut le
savoir le faire surtout Massimo et c'est
un charmeur ça c'est toujours d'ailleurs
et voilà et alors là vous commencez
quand même à être un peu victime faut
dire la vérité dans le milieu que vous
fréquentez un peu victime de moquerie
racisme de la part des gens parce que
aujourd'hui ça fait aucune impression à
l'époque certains chocs dans les
milliers dans lesquels j'étais déjà
disons avec mes copines il y avait mon
âge et tout ça et surtout mes amis
playboys qui m'ont tout de suite et midi
tu dois la quitter si on peut tout ça et
c'était
idiot de ma part parce que à la fin
après des ans j'ai suivi les conseils
des amis on doit jamais suivre les
conseils
quoi j'ai dit une connerie ou quoi
c'est un peu la boulette mais bon pardon
et là et là donc ça commence à devenir
chaud pour notre ami Massimo parce que
il y a les mais il y avait mais elle
commence à parler de mariage alors ma
jumeau il a quand même 25 ans à 83 donc
il se dit
donc vous êtes pas marié et là alors il
y a un truc mais ce livre il faut
absolument le lire là je le montre avec
la caméra parce qu'il y a un moment
extraordinaire c'est que Massimo est
dans l'intimité avec Lydia des Tardi et
elle lui dit je vais vous montrer une
photo et elle ouvre un petit un petit
coffre comme ça il y a lui montre une
photo et ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
que son mari le Fondateur de la chaîne
avant la guerre avait rendu visite à
Hitler dans le nid d'aigle
ont été des livres sur l'amitié de son
mari est très voilà c'est une gonzesse
en fait cette dame pardon
Hitler et donc ils avaient passé un
déjeuner à berchton Gadenne avec
Hitler et vabron Lydia lettering et son
mari et après le déjeuner elle était
devenue la maîtresse d'Hitler et là vous
vous retrouvez devant elle dit vous
dites au passage qu'elle vous a avoué
Hitler était pratiquement impuissant
ce qui explique que pas mal de choses ce
qui explique pas mal de choses et là là
vous êtes bouleversé quoi vous vous
dites je tiens dans mes bras
ont été persécoutés par les fascistes en
Italie je suis né en famille socialiste
et tout ça
deux ans que moi ont été touées par les
fascistes en Italie et alors vraiment
j'avais un championnat ça m'est bloqué
même sexuellement après
c'est que la gonzesse est couchée avec
Hitler sinon il y a pas de problème ça
bloque en même temps et alors là vous
êtes bon elle elle vous elle veut
toujours rester avec vous elle vous
propose de vous monter une affaire de
décoration vous revoyez Sagan à ce
moment-là et Lydia détruit entièrement
la décoration je parle comme toi
entièrement tiens dans les yeux du pire
belle-mère et elle détruit entièrement
et alors donc elle détruit la décoration
de l'appartement qui avait qui avait
coûté fortune il y avait des tableaux de
Dali tout ça elle détruit tout tout
jusqu'aux ampoules à l'arrache elle
arrache les douilles dans deux jours en
deux jours dans deux jours après j'ai
découvert scandale de décorateurs les
architectes vous disent que on a besoin
d'un an six mois pour faire maison c'est
pas vrai parce qu'après pour la
reuillage j'ai demandé qu'elle aimait la
maison comme elle était avant il avait
fait dans 15 jours voilà Massimo lui a
dit ouais Massimo lui dit ah bon il
serait concilier il lui dit mais
l'appartement t'en fais pas chérie deux
jours après l'appartement était de
nouveau comme avant les ampoules les
douilles tout autour d'où les ampoules
voilà bon voilà je pourrais continuer
comme ça après tout ce qui a acheté le
bouquin c'est chez Michel Lafont c'est
plat parce qu'après ça continue là je
fais juste un petit peu là je dois être
là même pas la moitié là ah c'est c'est
une vie extraordinaire Massimo gardien
[Applaudissements]
des fois où trouver vraiment des grandes
amies qui vous sauvent des situations
extraordinaires parce que
vous comprenez dans les milieux disons
qu'il n'est pas le Jet 7 vous trouvez
des grandes amies mais les grandes amies
officiellement des mots de confort
pendant si vous avez trouvé un grand ami
de le directe il peut vous changer la
vie dans les moments des visages vous
faites sortir des prisons très
pragmatique il se dit tant qu'à faire
tant qu'à aimer les femmes autant
qu'elles soient riche tant qu'à avoir
des potes autant qu'il soit dans la
jet-set voilà c'est tout Maxime en tout
cas on est malheureux c'est même être
malheureux dans une rose que dans un
métro non c'est ce qu'on appelle la
théorie de massimogardia qu'est-ce que
vous détestez dans la Jet 7
les gens où les tester mais en général
qu'est-ce que vous n'aimez pas dans la
Jet 7 la croûte est de vrais cruauté
quel est votre jet setter préféré
c'est un discussion il va en apprendre
elle arrive elle arrive celui que vous
haïssez une idée non pas par exemple
tout le monde le sait on sait pas avec
manuel de Brandt
Thierry Roland
de votre vie plus beau moment de votre
vie de toute votre vie les plus beaux
moments de ma vie
c'était quand j'ai vu là aussi que
j'étais capable de travailler que
j'avais du succès la première soirée que
j'organisais pour join anniversaire
c'était un triomphe et tout le monde m'a
dit tu es extraordinaire c'était
j'ai vu que c'était je pouvais commencer
par travailler autrement que comme les
castors le pire moment de votre vie
c'était quand sans être coupable j'étais
accusé dans l'histoire à Marrakech
la plus belle nuit de votre vie c'était
les premières fois que j'arrivais à
Paris et je suis allé en dîner ou l'été
était lors je suis arrivé il y avait de
l'or partout il y avait un arbre en or
dans le salon
donc ça c'est la plus belle nuit la nuit
la plus moche
il y a tellement des nuits blanches
surtout aujourd'hui l'endroit où vous
rêveriez d'être en ce moment si vous
n'étiez pas avec nous
vous êtes sur un bateau à la mer
et l'endroit où vous détesteriez ce soir
ce soir le seul endroit voudriez
vraiment pas être moi je n'aime pas
Massimo qu'est-ce qu'il y a de plus
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de plus sexy chez
vous
et de moins sexy la quéquette
toujours le moment
parce que ça vous obsède dernière
question ce que vous préférez dans le
sexe je préfère le début du sexe
est-ce que vous détestez dans le sexe
dans les sexes c'est la haine après
quand vous quittez la femme quand on
change les serrures
merci merci mon gardien
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu